this is where data shows a batch of
shots like on The Bachelor we're on our
creepy drive this group date I can't
watch that show do you feel like we're
on a group date
cuz it gives me weird I feel as a being
a group of ladies vying for one guy I
just worry about one person getting mono
and the whole thing going down the best
thing you could get that's like that's
just me so there's the bachelor so this
feels like an SNL reunion yes you'd like
you just what do you guys talk about it
there's so much like our old favorite
sketches we have we have fun we have fun
light times and laughter and making each
other laugh line then we can then you
could also talk about like you know your
deepest anxiety which is a great balance
of that I look for in any friend oh I
love that and shut those fountains oh
that wasn't like I thought that was I
thought that that was like a I never
mind a hearing loss that I had suffered
and it was good so this group of girls
when you guys are all drinking who would
you say is the last one standing and the
first one down they say polar checks out
fast she just puts herself to bed she
gets herself to bed that's true she just
did this good self-care yeah that's it I
don't mean say she parties with everyone
but then when it's time for to like self
care at she's gonna I was going to say
these gals can hold their liquor they're
not a bunch of wimps last one standing
commuting I'd say maybe Paula Hobbie
Polar's 5e yeah yeah I thought it was
you me the three of them voted for you
Bailey you are you like they said that
you love the TV show last man standing
if you were to pick other celebs to join
your wine group who would you pick Dave
Matthews we have Kathie Lee Gifford and
Hoda Kody would be in Oprah would be in
let's think of some fun winos Kelly Ripa
I think it hang yeah I'm sure good she's
a good Jersey girl but she would make us
do too much SoulCycle no I'd be like I'd
be like SH girl don't wake me when you
leave for SoulCycle yeah
quietly down the hotel hallway tread
lightly towards here I'm greedy the
mascot of the Flyers that's a good oh my
gosh Carol Burnett we'd worse that's
comedy icon yeah we couldn't have how
many other people yeah they're open at
you're out Oprah you're re Oprah Kelly
you're out so let's play a game quickly
the wine edition of would you rather yes
rather this is a good one be drunk at a
kid's birthday party that I have or your
first day on set for a thumb Oh kids
birthday
you pretty much needed to be drunk and
you also know how you know how to handle
it you've done it before
yeah okay hungover hosting the Oscars or
hungover walking the red carpet at the
Met Gala Oh
Oscars hungover at the Oscars mmm Mecca
on carpet there's too many stairs so
dangerous but it's outdoors I don't know
I don't have a good answer for ya okay
um who's never be able to drink wine for
ten years or have to only drink box wine
for the rest of your life
Fox - done there's some real quality you
could have tequila though or something
we're just talking wine I mean really
good you're so you turned out and box
wine for eternity no I'm just thinking
what I'm thinking so that's a toughy the
only problem with a box wine is that you
well i buy a real solid box Briana I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna make you
uncomfortable hashtag hashtag vrak
checks vrse anyway I put it in my fridge
at Fire Island and the problem is that
it's like a spigot yeah that wasn't all
there on your life that much and before
you know it the whole bladders empty box
wine she just made it sound good
could I get a box and put my own wine in
it cute Felton coupons on like that one
the phones agree okay so you guys are
just gonna do box wagons there's going
to be dancing waters to some of our
greatest hits coming up
you